floor-length gowns towering heels and
most famous red steps
it's another premiere at the Cannes Film
Festival actress Cate Blanchet touches
down with help on standby everyone's
keen to put their best foot forward here
but it's the Fashion Police rather than
the frocks that are making headlines
after women in flat shoes have allegedly
in turned away producer Valerio Richter
told Sky News she was stopped four times
at a gala this week despite a visible
disability two years ago I had part of
my left foot amputated so I can't really
wear heels anymore we're all working
women that can so you walk around you
stand around your feet get really tired
at the festival and so the last thing
you really want is to stand on on high
heels just for a three-minute walk of a
red carpet and she's not the only victim
British director Steve Kapadia his Amy
Winehouse documentary premiered at can
said his wife had also been stopped for
shunning stilettos but was eventually
let in a backlash on social media has
followed with women posting pictures of
their comfortable shoes with the hashtag
shame your flats now even the stars are
stepping in everyone should wear flats
to be honest the best attire I think we
shouldn't wear high heels anyway but um
that's just my point of view I just
prefer wearing converse sneakers but um
yeah that's a very disappointing
obviously it's very disappointing you
kind of think that there's these new
waves of equality I'm gonna wear that
now for that reason are you kidding me
well women should be able to wear
whichever suits them the festival says
it has no formal policy on footwear but
the PR stumble is particularly awkward
in a year when kin was seeking to
address sexism in cinema we shouldn't be
forced to wear heels us I mean look at
fashion and how it changes almost
anything goes in fashion I think a film
festival off of the scope and with the
glamour that can has should follow in
the footsteps of fashion and actually be
much more inclusive of what's allowed on
the red carpet it seems they're still
lots of work to be done the four
inequalities is
truly stamped out sorry Gary Sky News